welcome to episode 27 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i spoke with dr bjorn
lomborg
dr bjorn lomberg is president of the
copenhagen consensus center
and visiting professor at copenhagen
business school the copenhagen
contestant center
is a think tank that researches the
smartest ways to do good
for this work lomborg was named one of
time magazine's 100
most influential people in the world his
numerous books
include the skeptical environmentalist
coolit
how to spend 75 billion to make the
world a better place
prioritizing development a cost-benefit
analysis of the un's
sdgs and the nobel laureate's guide to
the smartest targets for the world
2016 to 2030. he's really cool
we spoke about climate change mainly
what's real what's not what to do about
it if you need a scientifically accurate
episode on climate change
this is it everything climate change you
want to know
i hope special thanks to true local
for sponsoring this episode and making
this podcast possible i have a new setup
that you guys will see soon when i run
out of
older episodes partly made possible by
true local
so sincere thanks to them they offer
flash frozen meat deliveries sourced
from local farmers who raise animals in
a sustainable fashion
you can go to truelocal.catru local.ca
and use the code mp for free steaks
with your box you can put whatever you
want in the box i usually do lamb
strip loin and wild salmon but they also
have chicken and pork and a ton of
pre-seasoned meat if you're not on my
lion diet
which is without spice and without fun
kidding guys
it's totally fun i digress if you're in
canada and you want really high quality
meat check these guys out true local
also buy an air fryer seriously put the
true local steaks in the air fryer for
eight minutes per side and boom
breakfast lunch and dinner with no prep
necessary that's truelocal.ca codemp
as usual for free steaks and of course
check out bjorn's book false alarm
i read it in preparation for the podcast
and it was really interesting
delves into the real statistics behind
climate change and offers actual
solutions
enjoy the episode
[Music]
bjorn lombard welcome to my podcast
thank you very much it's great to be
here i'm really excited to have you on
uh my dad actually suggested having you
as a guest and i believe he spoke to you
on his podcast a number of years ago
uh and my initial response was i'm not
particularly interested in climate
change maybe because i don't know
anything about it
then i read your book and it was very
interesting and i really enjoyed it
so i figured let's have you on and try
and like dig
through some of the information that
we've been told or that
like people don't really know a lot
about the truth behind climate change i
don't think
so if you would would you
tell people a little bit a little bit
about your background and what it is
that you do
yeah so look i'm an academic uh
uh i'm a social scientist uh and i used
to work in something entirely different
but i always told my students you know
uh you gotta you know do stuff that's
interesting you gotta look at
things that that sort of get you to
think and we did a lot of different
things
uh but one of the things i did uh was
there was this i read an interview with
an american economist who said
you think everything about the
environment is getting worse
and that's actually wrong and yeah i'm
an old greenpeace guy i used to have
like the posters on the wall and
on the badge and my backpack and all
that and i just thought oh
crap right but he said one thing that
really annoyed me he said
go check the data because that was what
i always told my students you know go
check the data
don't just believe the stories that you
hear but actually look at
what does the data tell you and it turns
out you know and if you think about it
it's kind of obvious
in the rich world we've actually fixed
many of our environmental problems we've
cleaned up the air you know air used to
be terrible 100 years ago
and now it's really nice most places in
the rich world
likewise with our water it used to be
terrible you know 40 50 years ago
now you can bathe most places so we
have fixed a lot of things it's not the
same thing as saying that there are no
problems
certainly not but it's a question of
saying
if you start realizing look not
everything is getting worse and worse
you can both stop you know being
panicked
and you can start thinking about all
right so what are the things we
really need to fix that still remains
and that's the conversation that i've
then been you know stuck in the last
20 years i thought i was going to go
back to my totally uh uh
unimportant research i did computer
simulation and
and uh game theory and you know kind of
stuff that a hundred people would read
if you were lucky
uh but what i've been spending my last
20 years on
is really to get people to realize look
there's still lots of problems in the
world
we don't have enough money to fix
everything so shouldn't we start talking
about
what are the places where we can spend
an extra dollar
and do the most good climate is one of
those areas where we definitely should
be spending resources
and think about how we deal with it
smartly but i do worry and i think we'll
get into
a lot of that conversation that because
we over worry so much about climate
we end up spending enormous resources in
climate often very poorly
and that means we forget a lot of the
other obvious issues
you know one obvious issue is covet
right now that we sort of
you know didn't think about before and
we knew it was coming
so let's get our priorities straight
let's focus on climate as well but let's
focus on it
smartly that's really what i try to do
okay
uh i think that message is good too
because you can't just give somebody
like
the we're doomed there's nothing we can
do about it or
we have to act now and we're not gonna
we're we haven't made any progress
anyway it's not gonna happen
uh it's a lot better saying you know we
have clean water things are improving
but
here's where we can improve more here's
where we need to focus so how
in your book you go into detail about
how you decide what we should be
focusing on
and i think my argument about why i
wasn't particularly interested in
climate change was
i've been more focused on i had a like
an autoimmune disorder
it was like no one with an autoimmune
disorder really is going to care that
much about anything other than
trying to not have an autoimmune
disorder so how do you decide to focus
resources on climate change versus
disease versus poverty
like and i you do something called cost
cost benefit analysis yeah can you get
into that a little bit because that was
really interesting so so look
obviously if you have an autoimmune
disease did i get that right
yeah i am then you know that's the only
thing that's on your mind
and likewise if you ask a teacher you
know what should we focus on
it's not surprising that they will tell
you better schools and doctors will tell
you better health care systems
and climate researchers will tell you
climate you know that's how the world
works and that's fine
you know we should be aware of all the
different problems that are out there
but we also need to ask all right so
what's the smartest thing that i can do
for hospitals
what's the smartest things i can do for
schools what's the smartest things i can
do for climate change
and then ask how much good is that going
to do because some things we do
have tremendous benefit some things very
very little so you know in hospitals we
know this all the time
you know there are some diseases that
you can fix by basically giving kids
an autoimmune shot a vaccination
very early in their lives and lots of
these kids are not going to die
that turns out to be a very very
effective investment
because we spend a little money and we
get a huge benefit lots of kids not
dying
that's why we do this in the rich world
and you obviously do it more and more
and that's why it's crazy when some
people are saying they
don't want to vaccinate their kids but
that i think is a different conversation
but you know fundamentally the idea is
we do this a lot in the rich world
we have started doing much more in the
poor world but there's still
so much more we can do just to give you
a sense it turns out
that for about a billion dollars we
could give vaccinations to so many extra
kids in the third world
a lot of them get the very simple ones
but there are lots of other vaccinations
you could give
we could spend a billion dollars and
save a million
kids live how how come we are not doing
that
well one easy answer is because it gets
no media attention
it's not sexy it's not fun but i would
say you know
giving a thousand dollars is saving a
kid's life you don't know exactly who
you're saving right because you
it's deaths that don't happen which is
also one of the reasons why it doesn't
resonate as much with people
but it still is an incredibly important
thing to think about likewise with
climate
you know so climate is a real problem
climate is going to make
life worse in the future not
you know apocalyptically worse but worse
and so it's a real issue to say all
right if we cut
carbon emissions that's the main reason
why we get
more global warming we can actually
reduce
future damages and you have to do a lot
of modeling on
looking at exactly what will happen but
you know the short version is this
if you spend an enormous amount of money
you can change the temperature a tiny
tiny bit
in a hundred years and not surprisingly
unless you do that really smartly it
turns out
that you actually spend much more
resources and help fairly little
and that's why cost benefit analysis
which basically tries to
make these costs and benefits across all
these different areas
tell you that unless you do it really
smartly on climate
we're wasting resources but there are
some smart ways and that's of course
part of what my book is about i'm sure
that's part of what we're going to be
talking about but it's basically about
saying
if you spend a dollar how much good do
you do saving lives
making lives better making sure
ecosystems don't collapse or don't
deteriorate making sure that everybody
lives on a planet that they like more
and you do that you look into all the or
you try and look into as many variables
as you can behind
these like decisions and that's part of
what cost benefit
analysis is right instead of just saying
you know you had an example about
vaccinating children in third world
countries where
people don't uh people don't realize
that in order to get vaccinated the mom
has to take half a day off of work
they don't take those kind of things
into consideration which i thought was a
really interesting way of actually
looking at problems because people don't
estimate some of the issues behind
wow any type of action um okay let's
start
like back a little bit so just climate
change
in general because i had i asked my
audience kind of what kind of questions
they had and a lot of people were like
the main question i think was how much
of this is actually our fault
that was just so just basics here yes
and
and and again remember i'm a social
scientist so i try to worry a lot about
how do we make smart policies on this on
the natural science bed
i simply rely on the u.n climate panel
the so-called ipcc
which is the gold standard this is what
the un sets
up with thousands of of researchers
trying to come up with what's the best
answer and what they tell us is
that more than half so somewhere between
50 and 100
of the temperature rises that we've seen
since 2000 sorry 1950
is our fault because mostly we emit more
co2
you know we burn fossil fuels uh so
there's a bit
of other stuff around that but yeah
roughly
somewhere between half and all of the uh
of the increased warming that we're
seeing
is awful okay okay and
what about okay so i read an article the
other i don't
remember maybe probably the other year
about how china's becoming one of the
lead
places dealing with renewable energy and
dealing with the climate problem
what are your feelings on that is that
true or is that media
what's going on there so there's there's
an important conversation to be had
when global warming is all about how
much does humanity emit of co2
so it doesn't really matter what you do
or what i do it matters what everyone
does
and so if rich countries think about
what can we cut
of carbon emissions but forget to
include
china india and everybody else it
doesn't matter very much
that's why it is crucial that we find
solutions that'll actually
involve china india africa everybody
else
as well and so china and
india and africa and latin american so
every all the non-rich countries the
ones that are not part of the
oecd so you know there's what seven and
a half billion people
uh so about six billion of the world's
population
they will emit three quarters of
everything in the 21st century
so they are the main issuers of
more co2 which is going to drive more
warming now as you pointed out and i
think i understood that uh
from from the article uh people also say
ah but china is making lots and lots of
renewables so they're actually
trying to fix this and yes they used to
have lots of uh of coal fire power
but now they're increasingly going green
let's just you know take
one step back first remember china has
been
for all extents and purposes an
impressive story
you've basically seen a country uh lift
about
uh you know almost three quarters of a
billion people out of poverty
over 50 years they've gone from being
poorer than
uh people were in latin america or in
africa for that matter
in the 1950s and 60s to being a
middle-income country they're very close
to
10 000 per person per year that's an
amazing achievement
and of course if you ask most other
developing countries
india at most countries in africa what
would you
like to do they'd like to look like
china
they have done that mostly by using lots
and lots of coal fire power
you know basically it means the
difference between having a life where
you don't have the choice over your
your circumstances uh uh you know having
access
to lots of electricity means that you
can pump water
that you can keep warm or cool uh at
night it means you don't have to burn
wood inside to cook and keep warm
which is one of the main reasons why
people die it means you can drive
the uh the uh engines of growth both
in agriculture and in industry that
takes you out of poverty and eventually
put you on path
for development now then people will say
but now they're putting up lots of wind
turbines and solar panels and ever
remember everything in china is big
so if you go there and you take a
snapshot of wow there's a lot of wind
turbines yes
but there's also a lot of coal fire
power plants
so the truth is yes china has done a lot
of this
but remember china went from being
powered
back in 1971 where we first have good
data from being
40 powered by renewables
to being about 11 renewables
today why is that because they just use
so much more energy
so sure they put up more wind turbines
they have increased a little bit
they used to be 10 so it's a little
better at 11
but they're nowhere near no so
fundamentally 9 out of 10 of their
electricity and everything else
comes from fossil fuels and that will
continue for
quite a while and that's of course one
of the challenges it doesn't help that
you and toronto or me and copenhagen
you know change our behavior a little
bit if three quarters of the world
is still going to use lots and lots of
uh fossil fuel
because their first priority is quite
frankly to get out of poverty
okay okay so that was one of my
questions was what can we do on an
individual level
uh you know we've gotten rid of plastic
bags and straws and things and like how
much of a difference is that
actually making so or driving electric
cars or putting up solar panels on your
house or turning
the lights off when you leave a room or
you know all that stuff
is there stuff we can do on an
individual level should we bother
so you should definitely do all those
things and there are a little good but
you shouldn't believe that this is what
saved the world so fundamentally
don't feel too good about yourself think
about this so
uh you know one of the advices to the uk
uh environment uh
climate ministry uh he often said you
know if everybody
if everybody does a little we'll end up
doing a little
it's not rocket science you know a
little adds up to a little
uh so what we've just done you know
environmentalists will
typically tell you you know drive less
and fly less and do all these things
the world has just done that we
basically stopped the entire world
because of covet
it's essentially as if we all did what
these told us
and what happened was it will have
virtually no impact on climate
the day when china was the most shut
down
they still emit 78 of what they normally
do
because you still have to live you still
have to heat your apartment you still
have to you know use electricity
so even if we shut down our entire world
so
you know if we shut down our entire
world as we have and also that there
will be a second wave
uh in the second half of this year if we
do all of that
scientists estimate that by the end of
the century the difference in
temperature
will be one thousands of a degree
centigrade
so you literally won't be able to
measure the difference
and so what that tells you is most of
the things we talk about
have a tiny impact it's not to say you
know by all means buy an electric car if
you can
but the conversations that we should
have is
is it a good investment for public money
to go into subsidizing honestly mostly
rich people
who buy electric cars to go drive around
and feel all virtuous about it
and the short answer is no we end up
spending an enormous amount of money you
know in the u.s you spend seven and a
half thousand dollars at least plus you
give them access to the
uh uh to the special high uh uh
partitions on the highway and all that
other stuff
you give them seven and a half thousand
dollars of
of extra subsidies each one of these
cars they cut
carbon emissions that you could have cut
elsewhere for about
sixty dollars it's a bad idea to spend
seven thousand five hundred dollars and
something you could have bought for
sixty dollars
and that's the real conversation that
once you start thinking about what works
and what doesn't
you stop doing the stuff that almost
have no impact and you start doing the
stuff that really does have an impact
yeah that's a lot it's it's too bad
because it's such an easy sell to say
drive an electric car will give you
money you're saving the environment
compared to actually
delving into the science it's much it's
not an elevator pitch what you're
suggesting right
no that's that's one of the reason why i
have such a hard time right because
you know look if you just say the world
is ending you gotta drive an
electric car that's sexy and easy and
wrong
uh mostly wrong right i would like
people to be smart about this but of
course that actually means
we need to start confronting all the the
fear and panic that's out there
get people to realize what really works
and do stuff that's often
boring and doesn't sound like you know
doesn't sound like a great slogan only
it happens to work a lot better so
what's your suggestion on
cutting carbon like how how would a
smart country do that
so the the fundamental problem is
cutting carbon
is to do something that you'd rather not
do remember we don't
burn fossil fuels to annoy greta
toomberg or anyone else right we
burn fossil fuels because it powers
everything we like about
civilization it gives you the
opportunity to keep warm and have
lighting you know us having this
conversation but also having food
remember
uh about half the world's food uh is
produced with fertilizer that comes from
fossil fuels
and power and everything else uh so uh
matt ridley wrote a book a couple years
ago where he
where he talked about you know what was
cool to be louis the 14th
the sun king right uh it was because he
had
lots and lots of servants you know he
had people do everything for him
that's really really cool but of course
the problem is it's not a sustainable
solution rate because it requires one
person having a lot of fun and a lot of
people being
servants most people wouldn't want that
sort of society
what fossil fuels have basically allowed
us or cheap access to
readily available energy is that we have
lots and lots of those
virtual servants you know uh we have a
washing machine
that means that most women don't and it
honestly was mostly women 100 years ago
that would do the washing and spent
about a day or two days of their life
every
every week doing really really hard work
or cleaning our houses we have a roomba
for that now and so on
we have all these technologies that are
powered mostly by fossil fuels
telling people i'm sorry you can't have
that it's going to be
hard work and that's of course we're not
going to get this
by telling people i'm sorry could you
could you dim your lights
could you fly a little less could you
drive a little could you eat a little
less
instead what we need to do is to
dramatically ramp up
investment in green energy r d and so
one of the points that i try to make in
the book
is to say fundamentally what solves
big global problems is innovation
and if if i can just give you one
example uh so
if you think back to los angeles in the
1950s
it was terribly polluted mostly because
lots and lots
of cars this simple sort of
environmentalist approach to that would
be to say
they've got to stop driving all those
cars stop doing that you know just
stop driving around and of course they
would have had very very little success
the real way to fix that problem was the
guy who in 1974
invented the catalytic converter a
little thing you put on your
on the uh tailpipe of your car yeah it
cost about 500
so it's not cheap or free and then you
basically fix
the of the the air pollution problem
that's why los angeles despite being
many more cars and many people more
people driving around and there's lots
of other stuff
wrong with with los angeles but the air
pollution in los angeles
is dramatically lower what that tells
you is
if you can come up with a technology
that
allows you to do all the stuff you like
but with much less environmental impact
almost everyone will do it and that's
why what we need to do
is to come up with a technology
that will produce all the energy we like
but with much less or zero co2 emissions
we're not there yet and i i think we'll
have a conversation
just about why we're not there but
fundamentally we need to invest a lot
more in research and development in
order to get there but once we get there
it's not just going to help people in
canada or in denmark or
you know in the rich world but of course
if you make green energy cheaper than
fossil fuels
everyone will switch the chinese the
indians the africans everybody else
how do you feel about hydrogen fuel
cells
so the idea here is there's a lot of
people out there who
you know a little bit like when you ask
uh you know the teachers
should schools be our top yeah yeah uh
if you ask the people who sell
hydrogen uh uh fuel cells they'll say
see
that's the future yeah this is the
answer we'll sell wind turbines we'll
say
wind turbines and solar panels and so on
the beauty is there are
lots and lots of people out there with
good ideas i love
for no other reason than that it's a
it's a fun idea craig venter the guy who
cracked the human genome back in 2000
so really really smart guy he has this
idea that he wants to
genetically engineer an algae to so
when you when you put it out on the
ocean surface it'll soak up
co2 and sunlight and produce oil
and so we just harvest these algae from
from the ocean
surface and we have oil that is carbon
free in the sense that it's just soaked
up the co2 so when we burn in our cars
there's a net zero to zero that would if
if that could work that would mean we
could keep everything we have today but
we'd end up emitting no co2
now obviously the reason why you haven't
heard of this and the reason why that
hasn't taken over the entire world is
it's not competitive yet it's a it's a
pilot idea
that in principle works but it's just
way too expensive compared to current
technology
and it's the same thing with the
hydrogen car and with hydrogen fuel
cells
and with all these other proposals most
of them are unfortunately still
too expensive but the trick is of course
it's
incredibly cheap to give craig venter
some extra money
to do more research likewise we should
give more money to the guys who are
doing
uh hydrogen fuel cells we should
certainly be giving money
to the people who are doing fourth
generation nuclear power
which potentially could be incredibly
safe and incredibly cheap
uh but of course you know we're not
there yet so we should do that across a
wide range of areas we should also
importantly do this
for solar and wind with batteries
because the big problem with solar and
wind is of course
what do you do when the wind is not
blowing and the sun is not shining
then you're stuffed we can't have that
so you need to have some way
of making sure you can store that one
way the hydrogen guy will again tell you
well we could yeah
yeah and that's also true but again not
cost effectively right now
so the problem is not that we can't fix
it in principle
the problem is we can't fix it in any
realistic way
that people would actually be willing to
pay for
that's what we need to change with
innovation
okay so you think one of the best way to
spend or spend our money is
give it to really smart people who have
good ideas and just see what happens
but yes simplify a little more of
regulation along those lines so they
don't just make fun of it yeah but yes
okay i like that uh what happens if we
don't end up doing anything like what
happens if
the our countries end up spending their
money in stupid ways and
we don't change anything really yes so
there's a real conversation about so
look global warning is a problem
to just get a sense of proportion uh the
u.n climate panel estimate that in
in about 50 years in the 2070s uh
the net negative impact of global
warming
they say will be equivalent to each one
of us losing somewhere between 0.2
and 2 of our income that's certainly not
nothing
remember it's also a lot less than i
think what most people would think you
know you get this
feeling that it's like the end of the
world no it's let's say two percent to
be on the safe side by 2075.
by then we will be about 263
percent richer than what we are today so
because of this two percent reduction it
will feel like
we're only 256 percent richer rather
than 263 percent richer
yeah that's a problem no it's not the
end of the world
so the the first point here is to
recognize this is a problem
not the end of the world that matters
because if you think it's the end of the
world
you're willing to throw everything in
the kitchen sink at it if you realize
this is a problem
you're going to say all right i want to
fix this but i want to make sure that
the money we spend
are not actually more expensive than the
part of the problem
that we end up solving yeah yeah so
that's why
when you when you then say well bjorn
it's all good with your idea
you know let's have creativity and
research and
and see if we can come up with solutions
but what happened if we don't find a
solution
now first of all i tend to believe that
we have shown
humanity over and again when you throw a
lot of people money at a lot of
smart people they come up with solutions
so i think there's a 95
chance but i've no there's no good
reason why it should be 1995 right but i
mean
there's a very high probability that
we're that we will fix it because we're
a resourceful
civilization but the real issue is
it's not the question of saying
obviously so there's a five percent
chance that we'll just be stuffed and we
don't know how to deal with it
i would still say then we deal with it
i'd much rather not be there
then we'll have to incur the two percent
cost uh in the 2075s and it's actually
going to get worse
uh towards in the 22nd century but again
you know it seems very unlikely that 150
years from now
we won't be so much smarter than we'll
know how to fix fix these things
but the alternative is not somehow a
matching
other way that we fix this it's simply
if you look at what we're doing today to
fix
climate change we're doing nothing we're
spending lots and lots of money
but we're doing virtually nothing just
to give you and i i quote this
in in my in my book but i think it's a
fantastic
and much underreported fact the un
environment protection
agency the un ep they went out
last year and told us that all of the
climate policies that every government
in the world have been trying to do so
obama and everybody else
for the last 10 years had an effect that
meant
they could not tell the difference
between what has actually happened
and a world where we just didn't care
about climate at all
so the fact that we've just spent
trillions of dollars on climate policy
over the last
a decade at least means we have nothing
to show for it
so my point is not to say let's go with
the 95
solution which is what i'm advocating it
is the alternative
is to go with the stuff that just
doesn't work but spends lots and lots of
money
so i think 95 cheaper so
95 success rate at much cheaper cost is
a much better idea
than spending trillions and doing
nothing uh but you know i can't
guarantee that we're going to fix this
oh that's so terrible to hear trillions
cause you could be using that money for
on things that actually do work
that's rough that's rough man and that's
exactly the point right i mean look i
think we have a moral responsibility
to actually spend our resources well
people will tell you and i think
a lot of people really mean this very
very honestly and genuinely
they will tell you we need to fix
climate change because it's going to
harm the world's poor the most and
that's absolutely true and it's going to
harm the future the most
that's absolutely true but we also got
to remember
if we don't fix as we talked about at
the very outset vaccinations for small
kids
that's going to harm their future very
bluntly by them dying
it's going to mean that they will be
less well off in the sense that they
won't be able to do
their education as well if we don't give
them enough nutrition
if we don't ensure that they have clean
drinking water and all these other
very very basic things that we can help
make sure
that especially the world's poor get the
best opportunities that they can
so it's not like there's just one place
you can spend your resources and very
often in the
in the public debate it almost seems
like there's just climate
but no there's climate and there's all
these other things that we should also
be focusing on
so let's make sure that every time we
spend a dollar or spend a billion or a
trillion
let's make sure we actually spend it
smartly
do you think trying to bring people out
of poverty
is like that's an interesting way to get
third world countries to be more focused
on climate change because those
countries
don't care about climate change because
they're trying not to die right so if
you can
bring those people out of poverty so
that they don't have to worry about just
eating is that the would that
potentially
be an effective way to fight climate
change kind of indirectly
yes yes so it very much is so prosperity
fundamentally is is something that we've
forgotten because
yeah most of the people who do the
talking climate
are well off people they're people who
don't worry about
where their next meal is going to come
from or whether they're going to be
warm at night or whether they're going
to die from an easily curable infectious
disease
so so if we get people to realize that
that's not where most of humanity is
if you could get them out of poverty
they would be
much more likely to be able as you say
care about climate change
but also just they would have many many
other things
that they wouldn't have to care about
and of course if you
stop being poor you're also much more
resilient to everything
nature throws at you so if you if you
think about a hurricane hitting florida
that's always a disaster but it is
mostly a disaster that cost
billion dollars and kills a few
but if the same sort of hurricane hits
guatemala
it'll devastate their economy for years
and it'll
kill tens of thousands of people as her
mitch back
did ban uh 1998 so the idea here is to
say
if you can get people out of poverty get
them out of you know
corrugated roofs and and shandy towns
they're not only much better off in all
these other wonderful ways
but they are also more safe from
hurricanes and they will have more
attention and resources to deal with
climate
yeah yeah okay that works um you talked
a bit in your book about
energy poverty which isn't something i'd
heard of
before so could you describe that a
little bit i don't think people know
about that
well i didn't no no and and look again
most of the conversation most polite
conversation
is among people who are fairly well off
uh
so i'm always astounded when i go to new
york uh
and and you know people casually at
dinner parties say
sure you know we could uh hike the uh
the gasoline
uh yeah you know they they take gasoline
in gallons right but you know instead of
costing what two four dollars
they say oh you know it should cost
twenty dollars and
you know if you live in new york you
have transit system right outside your
door
you probably never use a car and if you
do you have lots of
money to pay for it it's no big deal but
of course
many people especially far outside of
new york
live in a place where they basically
spend
uh and new york times did a survey on
the some some of the
poorest places in in i believe it was in
alabama
uh uh people spent up to 23
of their disposable income on gasoline
in order to get to their poorly paying
jobs
so very clearly for those families this
is absolutely essential and no they
cannot pay 20
or they can't even pay you know 10 cents
uh more on the gallon
and that goes to the heart of energy
poverty
that in most countries a lot of people
can actually not afford to pay for their
electricity in the sense that we say
do you pay more than 10 of your income
for uh for
electricity and and fuels both for your
car and for heating and all these other
things for energy basically
turns out that that's a lot of people
both in the u.s
across the developed world and certainly
a lot in the developing world
so if you for instance look at what's
happened in the uk
uh where it perhaps is most obvious uh
what has happened
you've enacted a lot of climate
legislation that has driven up
the cost of energy that's one of the
points of of climate legislation
that you make energy more expensive so
that people will use less of it
remember that harms the poor much more
than it harms the rich because the rich
is just like
okay my you know this little trivial
bill that i never really look at has
gone up
okay i'll just pay it so we can actually
see rich people don't cut
down on their emissions but poor people
do because they can't afford it
and so what you see is the pensioners
who are often the poorest of the poor
they end up not being able to heat their
own their
full home so we have surveys that show
uh more than a third of them keep not
their
full home uh heated simply because they
can't afford it
uh some of these pensioners will stay so
about 50
of them stay under their duvet in the
morning so they don't get up but they
stay longer than they really want to
in order to keep warm some of them also
take the buses because they have very
cheap passes for buses
so they'll go on buses all night to stay
warm instead of going home to the coal
department
those have real impacts and if you look
at what happens in the u.s
so we have a study that looked at what
happened with people
who couldn't afford to keep sufficient
heating in their house well about 11 000
more people died every year
from cold deaths what happened and we
know this because
there was a natural experiment uh you
had fracking in the u.s
fracking you know you can have all kinds
of
opinions about that but it made gas
cheaper in the u.s
that means the people who heated their
homes with gas
now suddenly had a lower bill so they
could afford to heat keep their homes
better heated we actually saw all those
11 000 people not die because
gas became cheaper so energy poverty has
a direct consequence
in that it kills people because they die
from cold deaths
but it also and sometimes also from heat
deaths but much more from cold deaths
and it just simply makes life much more
miserable
again it doesn't mean that we shouldn't
do anything about climate
but you need to remember just doing
something to fix climate
by hiking the energy price is not just a
positive as most people
in the rich world will think in this you
know the the
uh what is it the chattering classes is
that what you call them uh you know the
the the well-off people who make most of
this conversation but it also means
really poor people suffer oh
that's so horrible i i remember a few
years ago i think
i was reading stories about pensioners
in quebec and canada
who couldn't afford i think it was rent
like something they couldn't afford rent
because they'd
upped the energy prices so much
particularly in quebec
that it was just these old people who
didn't have any
money that were suffering and i was like
why isn't anyone it was like this tiny
little article in a
i don't know some newspaper but people
weren't freaking out about it online
it's like why are you
freaking out about it's just weird what
people it's very strange what people
focus on
because there's you can you can look for
like hurt
and terrible things everywhere but like
old people not being able to afford to
heat their house so they have to stay
under the blankets is really sad
that's really sad just just to follow up
on that
if you look at most places around the
world many more people die from cold
than from heat so in the u.s it's about
uh 16 times more people so about seven
percent die
from cold uh about half a percent of all
that die
die from heat so this is much much seven
percent out of
75 percent of all dead in the u.s so
what what is it uh uh
2.6 million people die in the u.s every
year
uh so seven percent of that comes from
cold
oh my god percent of that death so about
170 thousand people uh die from
uh from cold and about uh uh ten
thousand
people die from from from heat
thereabouts
uh so the reason why you don't know
the cold death is because that happens
slowly
so cold death is typically something
that because you can't keep your
home sufficiently heated uh especially
if you're old
your heart restricts of the uh the blood
vessels out to your
your skin so it gives you higher blood
pressure
and then eventually you're more likely
to have heart failure but it happens
over
months so there's no one snap a lot of
people die
whereas heat waves are typically what
kills people from heat
so you get it all in one go so that
makes it much more media worthy
which is why you hear a lot about heat
waves because those are you know
those are media fun they they get lots
of good pictures
but whereas cold deaths rarely ever make
the news
despite the fact that every year in the
uk it's also one of the worst countries
for a lot of reasons they have bad
insulation
uh somewhere between 25 and 40 000
people die from cold
uh deaths every year in the uk in just a
few months
just a few years back they had back
locks in the
in the uh more cherries for months
people couldn't get their loved out for
months because there are so many that
died
uh in a in a cold way but you don't hear
about it because it's not
sexy in the same way as heat waves are
and and so your point is exactly right
we care about some things
and forget a lot of other things and
that's where i try to say look we gotta
ask
where does my dollar do the most good
rather than just having the conversation
oh you know which puppy on on on the
youtube
uh video is the cutest
ah okay here i thought we're gonna have
a nice lighthearted conversation about
climate change
and talking about cold deaths oh my god
um okay okay switching topics a little
bit
can you give a bit of information about
this whole sea level
rising and millions of people are gonna
die
thing that i think everyone's heard
about like how much of that is true
what's actually happening yeah we can
start with that so
so i i actually use it as a great
example of how we're often
incredibly scared about climate change
so look
global warming means that everything
gets a little warmer
and one of the things that will get a
little warmer is the ocean because
the ocean just like everything else as
it warms up it expands
you will get sea level rise so we will
get sea levels
rising more that gives people the sense
of oh my god you know we're going to get
a lot of
flooded uh waterfront property around
the world
and what researchers will often do and
for a lot of
good reasons they'll simply say all
right if sea levels rise uh
you know at the very maximum perhaps a
meter uh by the end of the century so
that's not a trivial amount of of sea
level rise
a whole meter uh of sea level rise by
the end of the century
if you just map that on to what the
world looks like today
turns out that it'll flood an area where
187 million people live
so not surprisingly you know headlines
will tell you
187 million people will have to move by
the end of the century because of global
warming
this was the headline of washington post
lots of other papers around
both the us and across the world uh and
some of course went even further and
said 187 million people are going to
die they're going to drown although of
course they will have 80 years to
you know find another place but but the
problem with that argument is that it
assumes
that for the next 80 years we do nothing
so you basically sit in your armchair in
the in the in the in this house
close to the beach front and watch the
waves lap up over your knees and then
your hips and then your
chest and then you either drown or you
move but of course
that's not how any society actually
works we build protection
remember holland has been doing this for
at least 150 years
40 of holland is under sea level uh uh
under the sea right
um the world's 14th largest airport
amsterdam airport
is you know it used to be a site for one
of the big
uh sea battles in in the in the 1700s
it's been damned in and now is an
airport nobody goes there and think oh
my god we're going to get flooded
we deal with these things and we do that
routinely and at very very low cost
so the study that actually showed you
the 187 million
people are going to get flooded also
said
it's not actually going to happen
because obviously people are going to
take
adaptation measures they're going to
build sea walls and they're going to
nourish the beaches and all these other
things that we can do to actually make
sure this doesn't happen
and so realistically it's going to be
305
000 people that will have to move by the
end of the century
so 600 times less than what you were
told
remember that's a very very small number
that's about half the number of people
that move out of the state of california
every year
we can handle that globally over the
next 80 years i'm not saying it's no
problem but it's certainly a very small
problem
this gives you a sense of proportion on
the one hand you
hear about the 187 million people that
are going to get flooded
because that's what gives you the great
headline but it's not actually what the
research says
it's not what's going to happen it is
simply an
scare scenario it's not the real
scenario the real scenarios
we will tackle most of this it'll be
very cheap by the way
to actually tackle that but we will have
a
remaining problem of about 300 000
people who have to move
that's a very different kind of problem
than the
187 million people flood and that's what
i'm trying to do with the book
to say look we should look at the real
impact but we shouldn't
allow ourselves to be you know uh uh
inundated if you will
to use a bad word here uh by by these
incorrect arguments but often we are
because they're so much more sexy
and they just make for better stories uh
just a
month ago i i don't know if you saw they
even upped this
and they said about 12 of the whole
world is going to get flooded
uh and and you know it's going to cost
untold trillions and it's going to be
terrible and everything
what they assumed was not only that we
wouldn't build any new dikes
but that we would rip out all the dikes
we already have
now again again if you're a researcher
and if you just want to test out a model
it's not necessarily a bad way to do
this
you know if you're going to talk to some
of the other researchers who do the same
thing and look at how do you
fill up these different reservoirs and
all that stuff that's fine but it's
terrible for good judgment what's the
what's the mayor of new york going to
use that information for
here's what will happen with your city
if you tear out all the protection and
you don't do anything for the next 100
years
that's ridiculous it's only meant to
scare
and that's why i'm saying look global
warning is a real problem
but let's not make it into the end of
the world when what it really is
is what the u.n climate panel talks
about a two percent problem
by the 2070s yes it's a problem not the
end of the world
okay that's very interesting i've got
another one then
um coral bleaching
yes so so what's going on there and what
do we do about it
so coral bleaching and this is much much
harder and i don't know
the the right answer to that so there's
definitely some coral bleaching going on
because
sea level temperatures are rising too
fast
and so uh some of these corals are not
able to uh
to sustain uh they have a symbiosis with
uh some small algae
those are the ones that actually produce
all the color in the coral uh
if it becomes too hot they expo uh expel
uh uh those algae and that's what causes
the uh the bleaching
so there's a real concern that as
temperatures rise
we are going to have fewer coral reefs
now
remember at the same time we also know
that coral reefs have been with us for a
very very long time
and there's some studies that indicate
that corals are actually much more
robust
than what we believe but fundamentally
global warming is going to harm
some of those coral reefs and that's a
real loss
again some of the things that we can do
about it is to make sure that we
uh recolonize these coral reefs with
more robust
uh versions of the coral reefs so that
they will
rebuild in a more robust and sustainable
way
but like many other things in nature if
you want
to keep many of the beautiful things
you'll actually have to maintain them
and sustain them because you know once
you start being a human
and interact in pretty much all affairs
that is one of the things that you will
have to do
so i'm not you know there's no way
global warming
is just going to be fine and handy and
dandy and there's no problem there will
be problems
uh uh coal bleaching is probably one of
them
but it's not by any means the end of the
world again
okay um so back to the rising sea levels
you
in your book you spoke about something
called accretion which i'd
never heard of so i thought people might
be interested in that too yes
yes so uh when you think about sea level
rise
uh you know people talk about bangladesh
and they'll talk about you know
egypt and certainly you know in new york
and florida and all that
but actually the people who are the most
vulnerable and the people that we
most hear about are those small island
nations tuvalu
micronesia maldives that are basically
just a speck on the ocean surface
they're like one or two meters above sea
level and so obviously as sea levels
rise
you know they are literally talking
about this is going to be the end of our
nation that's what they
often say and that's certainly uh sort
of the the the argument last year uh
time magazine had the un secretary
general uh
fly into the tuvalu islands uh walk out
in his suit
uh in in the ocean and then they shot
the
the front cover of of time magazine with
the with the uh secretary general
essentially
suggesting this is what tuvalu is going
to look like in just you know
50 or 100 years what they forget is
remember since the last ice age which
was about you know 10
20 000 years ago sea levels risen 125
meters
so that's a lot uh yeah basically you
used to be able to walk from denmark to
england
and many other things right uh a long
time ago
20 000 years ago uh but but you know how
did these
small specks of islands keep increasing
you know how did they keep
becoming those islands because they're
actually natural
production of corals as we just talked
about
so what happens around these uh atolls
as they call
is that you have lots of dead coral that
every time there's a storm coming in
much of that dead coral get broken off
and some of that
coral will wash on shore so what happens
is
as sea level rise you're going to have a
diminishment
of for instance tuvalu but at the same
time you also get more coral washing in
which is going to lead to an expansion
of tuvalu
turns out that when you do the survey on
tuvalu and micronesian
maldives and all these other nations all
of them
are actually increasing not decreasing
in size
so despite the fact that sea levels are
rising which you would imagine believe
means that they become smaller the
accretion
from these extra bits of coral mean that
they actually expand
so overall the un secretary general and
and this was a a study in nature just a
couple years ago that basically said
so tuvalu is definitely safe for human
existence for at least another
100 years is simply telling us the wrong
story it's a very sexy story but it's
one a little bit like the 187 million
people are going to get flooded
it's a story that only tells you half
right if
sea levels rise and nothing else changes
if you i just forget for a second
that tuvalu and all these other nation
states are actually
partly created by accretion of coral
reef
rubble then we'll have a catastrophe
but of course you can't just forget half
of you know what
how nature works and if you include that
no that's actually not what's going to
happen now global warming is still a
problem
it's still something we should fix but
it takes away this
it's the end of the world it's you know
how are you possibly going to live with
this
and gets it back to much more it's one
of many problems
how do we fix it smartly okay
um next question nuclear power
i've had i hadn't someone reach out to
me who was interested in coming on the
podcast and he was someone who was in
nuclear power and he was talking about
how it's actually
one of the more sustainable forms of
energy and it's been demonized
so what's your view on nuclear power as
an energy source yeah
so so there's a couple things so nuclear
power is the only
large-scale energy form that we know
right now that you can produce and have
almost
zero co2 emissions so it's it's an
obvious
choice for a solution the second thing
is most people believe
nuclear power is a terrible thing right
because it shares the name with nuclear
bomb which is not a good thing
uh but actually nuclear power is one of
the safest
technologies if you look at the number
of dead
or how much electricity they're
constructed even if you take chernobyl
and three mile island
uh which and fukushima which really
wasn't a big issue uh but if
those are the big ones that we've talked
about it's very very minuscule the
number of people have died
compared to for instance coal power
which kills lots and lots of people
uh possibly up towards half or four
million of people uh
people every year mostly because we
don't clean the the uh
exhaust you know the the the smoke
stacks uh well enough
so they're it's very very safe as well
the real problem with with uh with
nuclear power and the reason why it's
not taking of the world right now is
it cost a lot of money so
existing nuclear power plants are a
great idea to keep so for instance when
germany decides to scrap
existing nuclear power plants that's
just dumb
you already pay for it you eventually
have to pay to dis
decommission it right now it runs
co2 free for almost nothing why the hell
would you stop that
that's just dumb and that was basically
because they they got very very scared
uh but building new power plants
building new nuclear power plants
typically is incredibly expensive and
they typically have
huge cost overruns so it turns out that
new nuclear power plants right now
is a pretty poor investment that's what
the fourth generation nuclear power
plant
so bill gates and many others have
invested in this they're saying let's
try to make
a new kind of nuclear power plant so
it's much smaller
that you can uh basically build as a as
a uh
like they did with the 4t models you
know on a on a
conveyor belt you just build them like
you know you serialize
production so you don't build this
artwork and then another artwork over
here which is really expensive but you
just build one
after the other and they just look all
look alike and they're a little bit like
container and you just
put it up and then it runs if you could
do that
they say that this will be much cheaper
much safer and basically that could be
the solution to climate change
so your friend or the uh the the the
questioner
is definitely right this could be one of
the solutions
my only reservation is we're not there
yet and remember
the other three generations of nuclear
power plants everybody told us oh it's
going to be
very safe it's going to be incredibly
cheap and of course it didn't
so so i want to see the data and that's
why we should be very careful not to get
sucked in by one kind of technology so
again the guy who says oh it's all about
wind turbines or it's all about hydrogen
or it's all about nuclear
no all of these technologies share one
thing
that they're too expensive right now to
imagine as solutions for most of the
world's energy consumption
but we should research on all of them to
make sure that one of them
becomes so cheap that'll basically power
the rest of the 21st century
great okay um okay last question
what do you i did have a couple of
people comment telling me that climate
change didn't exist
so like what's your argument for people
who
are i guess climate change deniers and
say no this is a natural cycle we don't
have enough information like
yeah i i think you know again i'm not a
climate scientist
but i listen to a lot of these smart
guys and i talk to a lot of these guys
and
you know we've spent a lot of resources
getting all of these guys together to
write all these un climate panel reports
and they're fundamentally telling us
look the basic
physics argument put up more co2 in the
atmosphere
slightly increases the amount of
retention of heat on the planet
so what you basically do is you put a
slight haze around the world if you will
make it a little warmer that's basically
why you have
global warming and that's why they
started calling it the greenhouse effect
at the very first right
you put a little more insulation around
the world you heat it up a little bit
it's very very basic it's very simple
and it's also what we're seeing in the
data
uh so you can have quibbles about just
exactly how much and we started off
talking
is it half or is it all of us uh all of
the
temperature rise that's awful we don't
know yet but we're pretty damn sure
that it's not zero and so the point here
is simply to say
if you have the best scientist telling
us here is a real
issue and we also know that it's going
to be a problem how do we know it's
going to be a problem well
you know people will always say but you
know is the world really at an optimal
temperature wouldn't it be
nice yeah it actually got a little
warmer well that's the kind of thing
that you and i would say because you
live in toronto and i live in copenhagen
right
and yeah they're a little higher
temperature might not actually be all
that bad
of course if you live in uh mogadishu or
in addis ababa or you know
some other really hot place you probably
have a different approach
but the real issue here is to remember
that all of these nations
have infrastructure that is built to
what the temperature was
about 50 or 100 years ago so we've all
adapted so you know helsinki
has lots of insulation and athens uh
here in here in europe
has a lot of cooling they're simply
adapted to where they are
so no matter whether the temperature
rises or
goes down you're gonna have a cost
you're gonna have a problem because
eventually you you have to adapt your
buildings to do stuff that they weren't
originally done for and the same thing
with all your infrastructure and
everything else
that's why it's costly when temperatures
diverge from what they used to be and we
know that global warming will make
temperatures diverge so there is a cost
that's what the uh you know lots of the
world's best economists including
a guy called north house who who won the
nobel prize in climate economics the
only guy to win the nobel prize in that
have basically spent their careers on
looking at so look
there is global warming so that's what
you should tell your your friends
it's very unlikely that you have this
whole conspiracy of scientists telling
you
uh that there is a problem but there
isn't no there is a problem
but you also got to listen to the
climate economists who
tell you well overall how big of a
problem is that going to be
and what they tell you is as i mentioned
it's 0.2 to 2
by the 2070s that's a problem but
not the end of the world and that's
because we're going to adapt to a lot of
this
that we're smart and we're an innovative
species we know
many of these things we can handle at
fairly low cost it's still a problem
so let's talk about how do we fix it
smartly but the real point of course is
and that's
in some ways the summary of my book is
if the problem is two percent make sure
you don't end up making policies that
cost you say
sixteen percent to solve part of a two
percent problem
yeah fundamentally if i have a ache
the right solution is not to cut off my
arm yes it fixes the
wrist ache but it actually ends up
making me much much worse off
and so we need to find a solution that's
proportionate
or actually does the most good for every
dollar spent
and then we're back to that conversation
about you know of all the things we can
do
where can we spend resources in the best
possible do
focus on making sure we spend more on
research and development in green energy
because that's a great
investment and that will very likely fix
climate change
but also remember all the other things
as we talked about make sure you lift
people out of poverty
so not only become their lives become
much better in all kinds of other ways
but they're also better able to tackle
global warming
and do remember uh you know to get uh uh
uh vaccinations to small kids in the
third world
where we for a billion dollars can save
a million kids there are lots of those
kinds of things so let's make sure we
get it all right
and not just worry about one thing and
only that
wow okay that was fascinating i think
i'm going to have that nuclear guy on
um that was really cool thank you very
much for coming on um
where can people go to find you so uh
they can certainly go to my website
which is just my lastname.com
lomborg.com uh and then uh we
we have a newsletter where that you can
also sign up for there and see all the
stuff that i write every
uh every month you can follow me on
twitter uh and then of course
you know you can buy the book uh which i
i'm i
i wanted to say very briefly so i've
written a lot of books
uh and normally i you know i'm i'm like
an academic so i'll go off on all kinds
of tangents and you probably heard that
a little bit here in the interview
but this time for the first time
actually in my career i've had this
really really tough editor she just just
kept saying
this is nice but you can write better
yeah so you just kept you know crumbling
up
this is nice the chapters and and and
and forced me to rewrite it and make it
even
clearer and sharper and better yeah so i
think my book is really
really sharp because she forced me to
just you know make this
one smart argument all the way through
so you know when i go back and re
i don't read the whole thing because i i
wrote it uh but you know when i go back
and read
parts of it i really think wow this is
i'm very very proud of of of of of of
that book
so i would say you know if you want to
hear more about this uh uh uh you know
it sounds
incredibly trivial and i'm not saying it
because i i make money it actually goes
to our non-profit uh
the copenhagen consensus uh but do buy
the book
and and i think you'll find that it'll
actually help you think smarter about a
lot of these things and you know
hopefully
it'll get you to start asking the right
questions and forcing your politicians
to do
a little better yeah well i i enjoyed it
and it wasn't complicated for somebody
who
doesn't know anything about climate
change and it and you did a good job
incorporating kind of stories in there
like i said about coral reefs or about
different countries or different
situations so i'd recommend it
um i'll link everything in the show
notes and everything but
uh thank you very much for coming on i
really appreciate it
it was wonderful to be here take care
take good care
if you enjoyed this episode please rate
it and leave a review
next week not even next week this is
actually a two-episode week i'm
switching up the podcast
to two episodes a week and so on
friday i'm releasing a podcast with
bitsteen an intro to bitcoin
have a good couple of days before the
next podcast is out
[Music]
you